Instructor: ES6
classes can also be extended,
and to show you that, let's make
an animal class that will take
in a name. Then we'll also have
a couple properties, this.thirst
100 and this.belly if they want
to eat something. We'll start
with an empty belly when they
eat. Then we'll have a drink
method, which will take the
thirst down by 10, and we'll
also have an eat method, which
takes in a food, this.belly.push
food. Let us return this.belly
in case we need that value when
we're calling this.eat. Now,
that is an animal class, where
it's just any animal drinks and
eats. Any animal has thirst and
has a belly that things can go
into in. We can make an animal
off of that class, like a rhino.
New animal, and the rhino's name
is Rhiny, and that should work.
We'll look at the rhino. Good.
Then we also have rhino.eat a
burger, because that's what
rhinos eat, and rhino can also
eat some leaves, and it can also
eat a zebra.
Cool, that's working for
us. We'll double check rhino.
drink as well. Good, as a rhino
drinks, the thirst goes down.
That is an example of a base
class that we have here. It
really works on its own. However,
sometimes you want to get a
little more specific, like what
if we had a dog? Dogs also bark.
How do I add that? Do we do if
this is the dog, then not...No,
what we'll do is we'll extend
this class of animal and create
a more specific class called dog,
so class dog extends animal.
Inside of that, we still have a
constructor. When we make a
new one, let's show you how
we're going to make one. We're
going to say const Snickers
equals a new dog, and we are
going to pass the name of the
dog, but also the breed, because
that's some information we also
want to stick along with each
dog. It takes in a name and
also takes in a breed. You may
think we'll do the standard this.
name = name and this.breed =
breed. Let's see how that works.
We get an error here. Line 27,
this is not defined. Why is this
is not defined? It's inside a
method here. Shouldn't it be
bound? The problem here is
that when you create a dog it is,
in turn, extending an animal, so
we need to create an animal
before we can create a dog.
How do we do that? We call
what's called super. When I
first was learning how to do
this stuff, it was really
confusing to me. I was like, "
What does super mean? I don't
really understand that." Super
means just call the thing that
you are extending, first. We
first need to create an animal
before we can layer on our
additional stuff. Simply,
all we do is we say super, and
that's going to create the
animal. However, what does super
need? Super needs a name. We're
essentially just calling animal,
like that, but the keyword super
will call whatever you are
extending, and it looks like it
needs a name, so we'll pass in
that name variable to them.
We don't need this.name anymore,
because this.name is going to
get set up here, as well as
thirst and belly and drink and
eat, but we do set this.breed.
Let's try that out now. If we
have Snickers...Oh, very nice,
Snickers already has a belly.
You can see the breed that we
just added, the name and the
thirst. You can see that it has
been created off of the
prototype of animal. Now, we
can also add our own methods on
top of that, like bark. We can
do something like console.log
bark bark. A dog snickers.
bark works just fine. But what
about snickers.eat? What does he
like to eat? Plastic we find on
the ground. Sounds good. Burgers.
All of the methods that we
defined on the initial animal
have been inherited because we
extended the animal. Same things
go if you were to change any of
these prototypes on animal, they
would filter on down to dog, and
filter on down to Snickers where
we actually created it. That
is extending classes based off
of another. Generally, the rule
of thumb I've heard is don't go
deeper than two or three,
because you can imagine how this
would start to get hellish as
you extend and extend and extend
away. One other thing you
can do is you can actually
extend native things, like the
array. We'll take a look at that
next video.